[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
وستون الخبر من كل ومن جميع ج
وانبه في نيويوركا سوف يعلو فوق صوت
محاكمه ترامب الكل متاهب لكن لا احد يعرف
ماذا سيحدث
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي المقال يرافقون
تنياهو الذي اقاله لتسكنات عسكريه والاخير
يؤكد ترك السياسه خارج الابواب لاسباب
امنيه
في خامس انتخابات تشريعيه خلال عامين
نتائج متقاربه في انتخابات بلغاريا ذخيره
اوكرانيا
ايضا
التطبيقات الصينيه لا تنتهي والتجسس عامل
مشترك
وربما الاخطر والقلق للج
انه يدلي بتصريحات غامضه تسمح للناس
باسقاط ما يريدون على كلماته لذلك وفي
كثير من الاحيان يمكن لطرفين من القضيه
نفسها المطالبه بدعمه هكذا لخصت الصحافيه
الامريكيه ماجي هابرمان شخصيه الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في كتابها
رجل الثقه الذي تناولت فيه فتره حكم ترامب
وربما هذا يفسر لنا راويه ما يحدث حاليا
في الولايات المتحده والاراء المنقسمه حيث
غادرت ترامب فلوريدا متجها لنيويورك حيث
سينكث اليوم في برج ترامب تمهيدا لمحاكمته
غدا بتهمه تهمه دفع اموال لممثلات الافلام
الاباحيه من اجل شراء صمتها على علاقه
مسعومه قبل انتخابات عام 2016 عده مصادر
قالت انه تم ايقاف جميع المحاكمات ومعظم
انشطه المحكمه الاخرى قبل الموعد المقرر
لوصوله كما اوضحت ان جهاز الخدمه السريه
واداره شرطه نيويورك وضباط المحكمه
يناسقان الاجراءات الامنيه لظهور ترامب
الحدث هو سابقه في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
راويه لدرجه ان محامي ترامب نفسه لا يعرف
ما الذي سيحدث
[تصفيق]
نظريا يجب التعامل مع تهمه ترامب الاخيره
مثل مئات التهم الاخرى الموجهه اليه وخلال
مسيره المهنيه تسير الخطوات كالتالي تدخل
ثم ترى القاضي لتقول انك غير مذنب ثم تحدد
الجدول الزمني وتغادر في الحقيقه الامر
هنا مختلف ولم يحدث هذا من قبل ولم يكن
لدى جهاز الخدمه السريه علاقه بالامر لذا
الاجابه على هذا السؤال هي انني بصراحه لا
اعرف كيف ستسير الامور واامل ان تكون
بسلاسه قدر الامكان ثم كي ابدا المعركه
لتصحيح هذا الخطا
[موسيقى]
تربي اعود للمدينه التي تركها الطواعيه
والتي تتحضر لمحاكمه هي الاولى في التاريخ
الامريكي الاجراءات الامنيه مشدده هناك
انتشار لحوالي 30 الف شرطي في مدينه
نيويورك طبعا من المتوقع ان يستمر هذه
الوجود المكثف لهذه الشرطه حتى مغادره
الرئيس ترامب طبعا هو سيقضي الليله هنا في
ترامب تاور ومن ثم سيمثل امام المحكمه
الثلاثاء سيتم اخذ بصماته سيكون الاجراءات
قصيره نوعا ما سيستمع الى لائحه الاتهام
ويقول بانه غير مذنب سيتجه الى مطار
غواديا سيذهب الى فلوريدا وسيخاطب الشعب
الامريكي في خطاب لانصاره ومؤيته وسيقول
بانه القضيه مسيسه وهناك ظلم كبير وسيقوم
بجمع الاموال لحملته الانتخابيه
معنا من امام برج نيويورك مديره مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي او تبقى
معنا بالاحرى ومن امام محكمه نيويورك في
منحاه مراسل العربيه طلال الحاج اهلا بكما
وابدا معك ناديه لانه سنتركك باكرا اريد
ان اعرف منك هل الاجراءات الامنيه زادت
يعني وطاتها حول المبنى الذي من المفترض
ان يصل اليه ترامب في اي لحظه
اهلا بك يا طاهر انا قبل ما اجاوب على هذا
السؤال بدي اقول لك الف حمد لله على
السلامه وعن جد انا كتير سعيده اني اكون
معك على الهواء مره
ثاني شيء بالنسبه للاجراءات الامنيه لا
تزال كما هي منذ الصباح ونتوقع ان تزداد
بمجرد وصول ترامب بين لحظه واخرى يعني
هناك عدد كبير من كاميرات التلفزيون
المحلي
والاعلام العالمي الذي ينتظر هذه اللحظه
وصول الرئيس السابق دولار تشون الى تشون
تاور خلفي هنا حيث سيكون مرافق معه طبعا
عدد من المستشارين المقربين منه طبعا
نتوقع ان يمضي الليله هنا سيذهب غدا الى
المحكمه
ليمثل امام القاضي ويقول بانه غير مذنب
لكن بعد ذلك لا نعرف اذا كان الرئيس اليوم
سيتحدث مع مؤيديه ومناصريه لم ارى ايا
منهم هنا في هذا المكان على الاقل حتى
الان او سيتحدث معهم من خلال الكلمه
المرتقبه له في فلوريدا لكن على كل
الاحوال هذه هي سابقه في التاريخ الامريكي
هو سيد الاستغلال الفرص وبالتالي سيكون له
موقف يسجل بالنسبه لعدد الصحفيين الذي
استطاع ان يستكتبهم هنا في نيويورك في هذا
اليوم وغدا وسنرى بعد ذلك كيف سيستخدم هذا
لجمع تبرعات لحملات الانتخابيه التي
استطاع خلال 24 ساعه ان يجمع خمس مليون
دولار حتى الان نعم نتحول الى مراسلنا
ايضا من نيويورك طلال الحاج طلال يعني ما
سيناريوهات المتوقعه لشكل محاكمه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب
كما تعرفون سيقدم الى هنا الى المحكمه
الجنائيه العليا في نيويورك
الساعه السادسه عشره بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي
عشر بتوقيت المحلي
وسيدخل من باب جانبي ولن نراه وسيتوجه الى
الطابق الخامس عشر وهو الطابق الوحيد الذي
يعمل يوم غداء جميع اللقاءات المحاكم
مقفله لتقليل اعداد الناس الموجوده داخل
المحكمه الى الحد الادنى وسيتم التعامل
معه كاي شخص اخر يتهم بيتهم خطيره ولكن لن
تكبل يديه هذا ما فهمناه حتى الان هو هذا
الاتفاق بين محامي ترامب وبين
الادعاء العام
للمحكمه
ومساله
اخذ صوره له ما يسمى بمقشط تؤخذ للمتهمين
ووضع رقم عليها وهو رقم سيكون في سجل
المحكمه ولكن قد لا تؤخذ له هذه الصوره
ولكن القرار لم يتخذ بعد في هذا الشان
والمفاوضات ما زالت دائره بعد هذه
العمليه او ما يسمى
سيتوجه الساعه الثانيه الثانيه والربع
توقيت نيويورك او الثامنه عشر والربع
بتوقيت جرينتش الى قاعه المحكمه التي
سيتراسها القاضي
وسيقوم
بعرض تهم على ترامب وسيعرض عليها ان
يقراها القاضي له واحده واحده ونتوقع ان
تكون اربعه وثلاثين 34
تهمه
العمليه كلها هذه داخل قاعه المحكمه لن
تطول اكثر من عشر 15 دقيقه وسيقوم القاضي
بتوزيع التهم على ادعاء وعلى المحامين
وسنعرفها جميعا حين ذاك لا تبقى معنا لو
تكرمت يعتقل وسي توجه
الى ساعود اليك بعد قليل انا وزميل راويه
تبقى معنا بس نشكر ناديه لانس ستغادرنا
الان ولكن تغطيه مستمره معكما اول باول
ولحظه بلحظه لهذا الحدث التاريخي شكرا لك
ناديا عود اليك بعد قليل طلال
قبل ذلك قال ترامب على منصته قال انما
يحدث له هو حمله اضطهاد وان الهجمات التي
استهدفته لم يشهدها اي رئيس اخر في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
لم يتعرض اي رئيس في تاريخ بلادنا لمثل
هذه الهجمات الشرسه والمثيره للاشمئزاز
لكنهم يهاجمونني فقط لانني اقاتل من اجلكم
هذا بسيط جدا لا يمكنهم شرائي ولا يمكنهم
التحكم به وهذا يخيفهم بشكل لا يصدق تمويل
حملتنا الرئاسيه دائما كان من قبل
الوطنيين من القاعده الشعبيه مثلكم
مساهمتكم اليوم ستظهر لليسار انه لا شيء
يمكن ان يدمر اعظم حركه سياسيه في التاريخ
حققنا اداء افضل بعده ملايين وملايين
الاصوات في عام 2020 لكن الانتخابات تم
تزويرها وسرقتها ولكن اليوم سنستعيد بلدنا
في عام 2024
هذه التصريحات من ترامب ومن قبلها تصريحات
محاميه والحلفاء الجمهوريين يبدو انها
تعكس استراتيجيه هذا ما نشرته صحيفه
الجارديان حيث قالت في تقرير ان ترامب
اخبر مستشاريه وشركائه في الايام الاخيره
بضروره التصعيد ضد مدعي عام من هاتنبراج
وبلغه اكثر حده وتنوعا والهدف التخويف
سياسي بحسب المصادر فور صدور لائحه
الاتهام كانت في صدمه لكن بعدها قرر
الطباع هذه الاستراتيجيه التي اثبتت
جدواها سابقا بحسب مقربين منه الهجوم وصل
لان وصف ترامب تراك بانه مختل
عقل اسم يهدد مستقبل ترامب السياسي بسببه
يمثل الرئيس الامريكي السابق ام المحكمه
للاستماع للائحه اتهامات طويله
مدعي عام منهج خصم تروم القضائي الجديد ان
قضيه تعتبر منسيه للعامه قضيه الممثله
الاباحيه ستوري دانيز ترامب صرح للمقربين
بانهم مستعدوا لتصعيد الهجمات والثاني من
مدعي عام منهاجا
بالفعل الى انه سيلاحق مدعي عاما هاتا قبل
اسابيع من تسلمه لائحه الاتهام وموصفه
بالمختل عقلي
وينضم الينا من جديد من امام ما حكمات
نيويورك في منهات مراسل العربيه طلال
الحاج اهلا بك من جديد طلال اود ان استفسر
عن نقطه وسائل الاعلام امريكيه تحدثت بانه
فريق الدفاع
ترامب يفكر بنقل محاكمته من منهات الى
جزيره ستاتين بولايه نيويورك ما صحت هذه
المعلومه وما الفرق ان نقلت المحاكمه من
مكان الى مكان اخر
يشتكي من القاضي وهو اخوان مرشن المعروف
عنه الجديه الكامله والحنكه القانونيه في
التعامل مع قضايا ولكنه معروف
الرحمه احيانا يقول ان هذا القاضي يكرهه
تماما ويحقد عليه وايضا هو يكره وهو
المدعي
الذي قدم الاتهامات الى لجنه المحلفين
العليا
جراند جوري وهم من قرروا توجيه التهم الى
الرئيس السابق وعددهم حوالي عشرين محلفا
وليس المدعي العام
ولكن ترامبي يتهمه بانه حاقد عليه يكرهه
وان هذه العمليه مسيسه برمتها كما يقول
ذلك كثير من انصار ترامب وحتى
المسؤولين الكبار في الحزب الجمهوري ولكن
يجب ان ان هذا الشخص
تولى هذا المنصب فقط العام الماضي بعد تم
انتخابه ولكن عمليه تحقيقات في الريشه او
الرشاوي الى
بدات في عام 2018
تحت
وهو المدعي العام السابق وتعهد بانه اذا
نجح في الانتخابات سوف يستمر في هذه
التحقيقات وبالفعل فاز العام الماضي
وانتهى بعد اربع سنوات من التحقيقات في
تقديم هذه التهم الى المحلفين لجنه
المحلفين العليا وهم من قرروا ادانت ترامب
عمليه نقل هذه المحكمه الى
مكان اخر لن يتم وهذا ما نفهمه تماما حتى
الا اذا اظهروا امام محكمه الاستئناف
العليا هناك سبب وجيه وسبب الذي يريد
ترامب نقله اعتقد انه في
للمحاكمه سوف يحصل على محلفين اكثر تعاطفا
معهم في ستات ايلاند في جزيره ستاتين
وهذا الامر لا
تردد فعلا ولكن لا يوجد ما يثبت انه سيحصل
او او ستستمع المحكمه الى مثل هذه الطلبات
معك اولا باول طلال ان شاء الله لمتابعه
ومواكبه هذا الحدث الكبير في الولايات
المتحده اعذرني على المقاطعه استاذنا طلال
بس انتهى الوقت ويجب ان نختم هنا ولنا
لقاءات اخرى ان شاء الله
طلب البيت الابيض جمهور بالالتزام
بالسلميه خلال جلسه محاكمه ترامب واعلنا
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في البيت
الابيض جون كار بان الاجهزه الامنيه لم
ترصد تهديدات حتى الان من مثول ترامب امام
المحكمه غدا واضاف كوربي ان السلطات
الامريكيه مستعده للتعامل مع اي اعمال شغب
اذا دعت الحاجه
ما قاله البيت الابيض اكده عمده نيويورك
اريك ادمز الذي حذر من القاء القبض على اي
شخص سيتورط في احداث عنف خلال المحاكمه
[موسيقى]
مدينه نيويورك دائما مستعده نعلم ان
السلطات انفاذ القانون في المدينه يجب ان
تكون مستعده لاي شيء قد يحدث اريد ان اوضح
اننا لن نتلقى اي تهديدات كبرى محدده
للمدينه خلال توقيت المحاكمه
لكن رغم هذه التصريحات فهناك يا طاهر تاهب
امني كبير في نيويورك استعدادات اليوم
الغد الذي تتخوف السلطات الامريكيه من ان
يشهد تصعيدا امنيا شبيها بما حدث في احداث
الكابيتال
[موسيقى]
مع اختلاف طبيعه مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه بتهم
جنائيه واحداث الكابيتول الا ان هناك
مخاوف من تكرار ذات السيناريو فوضى وعنف
وتخريب رغم ان مؤشرات ذلك قليله وفقا
للسلطات الامنيه الامريكيه لكن لمعرفه
الاختلافات بين المناسبتين يجب اولا
التذكير باحداث الكابيتول
شغب الكابيتول حدث عام 2021 حين اقدم حشد
عنيف من انصار الرئيس دونالد ترامب على
مهاجمه مبنى الكابيتول في العاصمه واشنطن
احداث فتحت معها اكبر تحقيق في تاريخ
وزاره العدل الامريكيه ويواجه اكثر من 930
شخصا اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم فيدراليه
الامر المشترك ما بين احداث الكابيتول
وبين مثول ترامب امام المحكمه بقضايا
جنائيه هو خطاب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
لمناصريه لكن المختلف هو توقيت الخطابين
في احداث الكابيتول كان خطابه ناريا
ظهر فيه قبل ساعات من الواقعه واثار
المئات من انصاره اما فيما يتعلق بمحاكمته
في منهات فاعلن الرئيس الامريكي انه سيظهر
علنا بخطاب لكن هذه المره بعد ساعات من
سماعه لائحه الاتهام الموجهه له فحوى
الخطاب غير معروفه حتى الان لكن المعروف
هو تاثير ترامب على انصاره وفي المقابل
ردات الفعل غير المتوقعه للمناهضين له
احداث الكابيتول مثلت درسا للسلطات
الامنيه بدات بعدها بمسح امني واسع
للمشاركين وتبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
بشكل اسرع وعلى الارض تجهيز مواقع الحدث
بحواجز معدنيه واغلاق الطرق وحتى قوى
بشريه ضخمه تغطي مساحه واسعه استعدادا لاي
طارئ
من المتوقع ان يكون هناك احتجاجات في هذه
المواقع يعني نتحدث عن مبنى محكمه منهاتن
الجنائيه وايضا حول برج ترامب حيث سيقيم
عندما يصل اذا نشاهد طائره ترامب تحلق في
اجواء نيويورك قبل هبوطها
دقائق صحيح
بانه سيتم محاسبه اي شخص يقوم بهذه اعمال
الشغب في ايضا نذكر المشاهدين طبعا في
مقابل من يقول بانه هذا امر قانوني محض
وصف ما يحدث له بحمله الاضطهاد وان
الهجمات التي استهدفته لم يشهدها اي رئيس
اخر في تاريخ امريكا هي يعني سابقه ان كان
قانونيه وسياسيه وفيها متاعب قانونيه
فيبدو انها لا تاتي فرادا لترامب مع عوده
ملف الوثائق السريه في فلو في تقرير لها
قالت ان وزاره العدل توصلت الى ان ترامب
فحص الصناديق التي تضم مواد سريه بعد صدور
امر الاستدعاء لتسليم الوثائق فيما يبدو
رغبه في الاحتفاظ باشياء معينه بحوزته في
منزله في التفاصيل الجديده تسلط الضوء على
الدرجه التي وصل اليها تحقيق المحامي
الخاص جاك سميث في سوء التعامل المحتمل مع
مئات الوثائق السريه في منزل ترامب
التركيز الان على نقطه اعاقه سير التحقيق
واشنطن بوست سبق لها القول ان المحققين
جمعوا ادله تشير الى ان ترامب طلب من
موظفيه تضليل المسؤولين الحكوميين اوائل
العام الماضي بشان هذه الوثائق السريه
والعنصر الاساسي في معظم قضايا العرقله هو
النيه ويحاول المدعون العامون والوكلاء
الفيدراليون جمع اي دليل يشير من الدافع
وراء تصرفات تروم من بين الادله التي تم
جمعها ان ترامب تجاهل طلبات مستشاريه
لاعاده الوثائق وطلبه من محاميه اصدار
بيانات كاذبه تدعي انه اعاد جميع الوفائق
وخلاف ذلك وكما هو الحال في القضيه في من
هات فاجراءات هيئه المحلفين الكبرى سريه
ولم يقدم المحامي الخاص جاكس مث اي اشاره
علنيه الى وتيره تحقيقه او عندما يتوقع
الانتهاء منه
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا روسيا تحضر نفسها
لدبابات اوكرانيا الغربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شدد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو على ضروره
ابقاء السياسه خارج بوابات المعسكرات
والتوحد من اجل بقاء اسرائيل على حد قوله
وخلال كلمه الله في قاعده عسكريه برفقه
وزير الدفاع اكدنا
اهو على قدرات الجيش للدفاع عن اسرائيل ضد
اي تهديدات على حد تعبيره
هذا كان بالنسبه للسكنات العسكريه لكن
ماذا بالنسبه للسياسه من جهه نتنياهو
الاعتقاد في الداخل الاسرائيلي يشير الى
امكانيه حدوث مصالحه بين الرجلين بعد ان
عزلانه نياهو غالنتا الاسبوع الماضي دون
المضي في تنفيذ القرار وذلك وفق ما ذكرته
مصادر سياسيه كيف حدث ذلك راويه
مراسل افاد يا طاهر ان نتنياهو لم يقل
جالنت رسميا ولم يسلمه رساله اقاله خطيه
موقعه بل ابلغه شفهيانا
[موسيقى]
بالنص لكن الامر لم ينتهي وفق وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه نتنياهو اجل فقط قرار
الاقاله ولم يتراجع عنه بسبب الوضع الامني
في البلاد نتنياهو يبدو انه ترك السياسه
خلف الابواب لفتره مؤقته فقط
[موسيقى]
اذا نحن بانتظار طائره ترامب ان تصل بعد
قليل ان تهبط في مطار
جارديا في نيويورك هذه صوره طائره ترامب
يبدو انها تحط الان في هذه الاثناء في
المطار في نيويورك وبعد كان بعدما كان
توجه من فلوريدا حيث كان في منتجعه قبل
ذلك ومن المقرر ان يمكث اليوم في برج
تمهيدا لمحاكمته غدا لحظات التاريخيه
يتابعها العالم اجمع بين مطائره الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب تحط في مطار
نيويورك تمهيدا لمحاكمه رئيس امريكي سابق
راويه سابق هذه السابقه قانونيه وسياسيه
تحصل للمره الاولى مثل ما ذكرت ترامب
سيمكوس الليله في برجه وغدا من المتوقع ان
تحدث المحاكمه وسط مخاوف من احتجاجات حول
المحكمه وايضا حول البرج اعتراضا على
محاكمه الرئيس السابق من مناصريه ومخاوف
بطبيعه الحال من تكرر احداث الكابيتول
صحيح اذا نتابع الدقائق الاخيره من تحقيق
طائره ترامب في الاجواء قبل ان تحط وصلت
يعني الى ارض المطار تقريبا قبل ان تحط في
هذه اللحظات اذا طائره الرئيس ترامب تحط
في هذه الاثناء على مدرج مطار لاغوارديا
في نيويورك تمهيدا لجلسه محاكمته غدا طبعا
كنا علمنا بانه مسؤول بالمحكمه حسب وسائل
الاعلام امريكيه قال ان المحاكمه من
المقرر يطهر ان تعقد الساعه السادسه مساء
بتوقيت جرينتش
اذا نشاهد هذه الطائره طائره ترامب وصلت
الى المطار تمهيدا لجلسه الغد جهاز الخدمه
السريه واداره شرطه نيويورك وضباط المحكمه
ينسقون الاجراءات الامنيه لظهور ترامب غدا
ترامب الذي قال نحن الان رسميا دوله من
الدول العالم الثالث حيث لم يتعرض اي رئيس
في تاريخ بلدنا لمثل هذه الهجمات الشرسه
والمثيره للاشمئزاز على حد وصفه ولكنهم
يهاجمونني فقط لانني اقاتل من اجلكم واضح
انه دائما يعني يحاول ان يخاطب جمهوره
بشكل مباشر لما لذلك من تاثيرات على حملته
الانتخابيه المفترضه وهو يعني يريد المزيد
من الدعم لهذه الحمله طبعا هذه القضيه
ليست القضيه الوحيده التي واجهها ترامب
طبعا التحقيقات معه باكثر من تصرف تصرفات
ترامب في انتخابات عام 2020 وايضا احتفاظه
بوثائق سريه تحدثنا عنها منذ قليل الغايه
سريه للغايه بعد مغادرته للبيت الابيض عام
2021 طبعا معروف بانه ترامب ينوي ترشيح
نفسه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه مره جديده مازال في
تصريحاته ومنها التي عرضناها قبل قليل يصف
الانتخابات السابقه نتائج الانتخابات
السابقه بانه بانه تم تزويرها
وسرقتها ويعتبر ويدعو الى استعاده البلاد
في عام 20 24 طبعا تهمه ترامب هذه
لاحدى الممثلات هي تدعى ستورميدانيا
بالايام الاخيره من الحمله الرئاسيه لعام
2016 وقالت دانيلز انها حصلت على المال
مقابل سكوتها والتزامها الصمت بشان لقاء
لها مع ترامب باحد الفنادق عام 2006 ترامب
بطبيعه الحال ينفي هذه العلاقه وكل
الاتهامات الموجهه له نعود بعد قليل
لمتابعه هذه الصور عندما
يترجل ترامب من الطائره قبيله توجهه الى
برج ترامب في نيويورك ايضا
الى الحرب الاوكرانيه ميدانيا تشير وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه الى ان الجيش لم يحرز اي
تقدم في مدينه بخنط شرقه اوكرانيا وذلك
بعد ان قالت مجموعه فاجنر انها استولت على
مبنى
من جهه اوضح الجيش الاوكراني ان قوته صدت
الهجمات الروسيه وما زالت تتمركز في ضخم
معنى من موسكو الان عبر
المحلل السياسي سيده اهلا بك يعني نحن
نريد ان نقف مره جديده عند هذا يعني
التناقض في التصريحات الروسيه والتصريحات
الاوكرانيه في المقابل تحديدا حول بخمه ما
الذي يحصل حقيقه
ليس هناك الكثير من التناقضات بين تصريحات
الجانبين
زعيم مجموعه
اعلن بان مجموعته قد سيطرت على مبنى مدينه
الضخموت وهذا ليس بمبنى في الواقع هو مجرد
مبنى تعرض لتدمير كبير
ولكن اوكرانيا تقول انها لا تنسى تسيطر
على غربي المدينه
لا يزالون يحصلون على الامدادات
لمصلحه قواتهم
مصممون على مواصله المعركه في بخموت هذه
المعركه لم تنتهي بعده هي تتواصل
وهذا تحديدا
يتفق عليها الجميع ان المعركه لم تنتهي
بعد
من موسكو عبر سكايب بافيل في المحلل
العسكري ونعود يا طاهر بعد قليل لنساله
سؤالا اخر ولكن بحكم يعني تغطيتنا
المستمره لترامب نقاطع قليلا تفضل اذا
نشاهد هذه الصور نتابع فعليا وصول
اذا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طبعا تعيش
على وقع ايام صعبه
وحساسه وهي تحصل للمره الاولى في التاريخ
السياسي
لرئيس ولايه رئيس اكبر دوله في العالم يا
طاهر تمام يعني نراقب كما كل العالم يراقب
تحركات وخطوات ترامب من الان فصاعدا عندما
ينزل من طائرته قبل ان يتوجه الى مقر
اقامته متى سيتحدث ما الذي سيقوله كيف
ستكون معنوياته هل ستحدث مفاجات في مثل
هذه الساعات الحاسمه لانه حتى محاميه كما
قلنا لا يعرف بالضبط يعني الطبيعه كل
الاجراءات التي ستتم بما انها سابقه لكن
بما انه بالشكل حسب ما قال مراسلنا طلال
الحاج لن يتم تكبير
واعتقال ترامب بالشكل لاي متهم طبعا نذكر
بانه دون الترامب هو اول رئيس للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يتهم بتهمه جنائيه
ونشاهد اذا هذه الصور لوصول طائره ترامب
وسط مخاوف مخاوف كبيره من ان يلجا انصاره
الى العنف
الصوره باتت اقرب الان وباب الطائره يفتح
في هذه اللحظات بانتظار ان تنزل ينزل
ترامب من هذه الطائره تحت العلم الامريكي
المطبوعه عليها وتحت اسمه ايضا اسم عائلته
الذي يعني
يدمر هذه الطائره بوضوح
هذه الطائره التي يطمح ترامب ان يستبدلها
مجددا بالطائره الرئاسيه في 20 24 ولكن
الكل يعتقد بانه هذا معتمد بشكل اساسي على
نتائج وخلاصات هذه المحاكمه على قرار
المحكمه الذي سيصدر بعد محاكمته اذا وصلت
طائره ترامب الى نيويورك تمهيدا لان يسلم
نفسه نلاحظ بانه ربما المساعدين بداوا
بالنزول ولكننا حتى الان لا نرى دونالد
ترامب يترجل من هذه الطائره من طائره
ترامب الخاصه به
طبعا الادعاء العام بمنهات بمدينه
نيويوركان طلب من ترامب تسليم نفسه على
خلفيه هذه القضيه قضيه
يعني علاقه تجمعه والصمت عن علاقه تجمعه
باحدى الممثلات
نذكر بانه غادر الى نيويورك للمثول امام
محكمه منهج
المشكله الان ليست فقط سياسيه انما عراك
قضائي هو متاعب قانونيه
للرئيس الامريكي تحدثت عنها في تقريره قبل
قليل وهناك اشتباك قضائي حتى مع المدعي
العام
عندما يعني مع كل الاتهامات التي يكيلها
له والردود القضاء الاعلام الامريكي يعني
طبعا كله الان يصب كل اهتمامه على هذه
اللحظات اجراءات المحكمه ستبقى سريه الى
حد كبير راويه اجراءات هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى
والعنصر الاساسي في معظم القضايا سيعتمد
على يعني قضايا العرقله من عدمها في هذه
المحاكمات ما الذي حاول ان يخبئه ترامب ما
الذي كشف عنه هل
معطيات جديده اوراق جديده في هذه المحاكمه
تكون يعني نهايه السياسيه وعلى الصعيد
القانوني كذلك ام انه سيتمكن من ان يعني
يخرج منها كما خرج من الكثير من الملفات
السابقه التي واجهته اسئله كبيره ولكن ليس
لها الكثير من الاجابات حتى الان على
الاقل طاهر سيكون هناك حديث سيتوجه به الى
انصاره بعد عودته الى فلوريدا بعد جلسه
المحكمه هكذا قيل وطبعا يعني ترامب وهذه
هذه هذه الصور التي
التي يعني مثل ما قلنا كتب عليها ترامب
اسمه باحرف ذهبيه
فيما انصاروا من المتوقع ان يستقبلوه
بحفاوه وهم
يلوحون باللافتات ويهتون للرئيس السابق
يعني
ولكن حتى الان لم ينزل ترامب
انضمت الينا مراسلات العربيه من نيويورك
ناديه البلبيسي ناديه يعني فلنتحدث عن
الانقسامات السياسيه التي افرزتها اتهامات
ترامب في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي
المره الاولى التي يتهم فيها رئيس اقوى
دوله بتهمه جنائيه
في الواقع ربما هذه الاتهامات
وحدت ثقوب الحزب الجمهوريه يعني نرى حتى
الان دعم للرئيس ترامب لا يزال يسيطر على
الحزب الجمهوري وهو الذي غيره في الواقع
اصاحب القيادات التقليديه للحزب وتربى
عليه وادخل ما يسمى السياسيه في حزب
الجمهوري لكن بالنسبه للديمقراطيين من
المتوقع ان يكون هناك موقف بالنسبه لهم
بان هذا الرئيس غير مؤهل لان يكون الرئيس
القادم للولايات المتحده
انه يكون مؤهل يحكم البلاد في السابق
ذلكم يرونه رئيس يدعو الى الانتقام يدعو
الى العنف وطبعا ما رايناه في الاحداث
الثالث من يناير في الاعتداء على مبدا
الكابت الكونغرس سنه السابقه في الواقع
ومن هنا ياتي التخوف من اعمال عنيفه حتى
الان
تسيطر على
مرافق المؤديه الى المحكمه والى
ترامب تشاور هناك اغلاق للشوارع الرئيسيه
وعدم وجود في الواقع لاعاده تدبير انا لم
ارى احد في الوقت
ينتظرون الى يوم غد لكن نيويورك معروفه
بانه ولايه ديمقراطيه ليبراليه لا يوجد
فيها مؤيدين للرئيس بشكل كبير لكن بغض
النظر هناك سابقه في التاريخ الامريكي بان
يتعرض رئيس لهذا التحقيق وقد يواجه تهما
تؤدي الى تجريمه لكن هذه ليست هذا التحقيق
الوحيد بالضبط ليس هو فقط دفع اموال
بطريقه
اصبحت الان تعتبر مختلفه للقوانين ولايه
نيويورك بالنسبه لجمعه التبرعات وبالنسبه
عفوا بالنسبه لقوانين الانتخابات
الامريكيه وما يحكمها لانه عندما دفع 130
الف دولار عبر محاميه مايكل في هذه
الممثله الاباحيه التي اصبحت شهيره في
التاريخ الامريكي يعني
عندما قال قارنب انه لم يستلم
هذه الاموال التي دفعها من جيبه
بدفع وكانها خدمات قانونيه لمحاميه الخاصه
ومن هنا تاتي هذه التهم الرئيس لكن كما
ذكرت هناك ايضا تحقيقات ضده في ولايه
جورجيا قد تثمر ايضا عن تجربه يعني لا
نعرف حتى الان يعني متى سيتم البنت في هذه
المحاكمه ايضا او اذا ارتقت الى محاكمه
وهي قلب نظام الحكم في الولايات المتحده
والاحتجاج على
نتائج انتخابات كان يريد ان يتلاعب بها
عندما طلب من حاكم او سكرتير الولايه
بايجاد اصوات اضافيه حتى يكون جورجيا هناك
ايضا تحقيقات في مؤسسه ترامب وبالتالي
ترامب يح
اصر البعض قال بانها ايضا قد تجربه لان
فيها معلومات تتعلق بدول مثل اوكرانيا
وايران وبريطانيا وغيرها يعني
رغم اعذريني ناديه تحدثتي قبل قليل عن
مايكل كوهن المحامي السابق لترامبو وهو
شاهد اساسي في هذا الملف من المعروف انه
يعني اصبح عدوا
لترامب كيف حصل هذا الانقلاب مسيره
العلاقه بين الرجلين كيف تحولت وكوهين كما
قلت وذكرتنا قبل قليل هو الذي دفع المبلغ
لستورميدان يلزع عام 2016
تماما هو مايكل كون من وجهه نظري يعتبر
بانه كبش فداء بان ترامب ضحى به من اجل
الحفاظ على على سمعته على مكانته على
امواله على ترشحه للرئاسه وبالتالي عندما
قررت عام عام 2016 ان يقود معترك الحيات
السياسيه الامريكيه قام طلب المحاميه الذي
كان مقرب منه بان يدفع هذه الاموال وبعد
انقلب عليه مايكل
لم ينفع له هذه المبالغ عندما طلبوا بها
طبعا قال بالنهايه بانه دفع له لكن هذه
طبعا ادت الى فضيحه كبيره في ذلك الوقت
واصبحنا كمحامي
الممثله الاباحيه التي قالت ان اقام علاقه
معها وفتح عيون يعني 100,000 جهه على
مايكل واتهمه ايضا بالتهرب من الضرائب
وتهم اخرى فهو راى بين هو الذي دفع الثمن
السي وثمن الشخصي لانه قضى عام من حياته
بالسجن وبالتالي انقلب على ترامب تماما
والان سيشهد ضد الرئيس السابق
ويقول بانه بالفعل هناك اختراقات وتزوير
السجلات رسميه ومن هنا هو يريد ان يجرب
ترامب قبل اي شخص اخر
لربما من ينتقل منه
ليعيد الحق الى مصابين كما هو يقول سنرى
ماذا سيتحدث في هذه الاتهامات اللائحه
ماذا سيقول وبالنهايه القاضي هو الذي يقرر
ربما القاضي لا يرى بان كل
حتى الان لا حتى محاميه ترامب يحاولون
الحصول عليها الليله قبل المحاكمه لا احد
يعرف انها اكثر من 30 اتهاما ولا نعرف حتى
اذا كانت محفوره فقط بهذا الاتهامات التي
تعتبر مخالفات قانونيه بدفع هذه الاموال
لهذه الممثله اما ايضا
فهموا فيما يتعلق
بمخالفات قانونيه اخرى يعني ترامب كان رجل
اعمال معروف ولكن يورث
وملياردار يعني كانت لديه اموال كثيره
وهناك الكثير من الاعداء الذين يروا بانه
حول التهرب من الضرائب اكثر من مره اعلن
عن افلاسه وهو الوحيد على فكره بين
الرؤساء الامريكيين الذي لم
لما لما يعلن عن قراراته الضريبيه
والبعض يرى بانه لم يدفع حتى
تم المواطن الامريكي العادي من الضرائب
لمده سنوات فهناك يعني الكثير من علامات
الاستفهام حول صفقات التجاريه وما كان
يفعله صفقاته علمانيه الى اخره الى هذه
التهم ان هي فقط محصوره بهذا الاطار
النزلات من طائرته واستقل سيارته ومن
المنتظر ان يتوجه بها الى برجه برج ترامب
في نيويورك وطائره لا تزال طبعا في المطار
حيث نزل منها قبل قليل
وصل كما نشاهد في هذه الصور الى نيويورك
وصل ليسلم نفسه وليخضع لمحاكمه لمحاكمه
بتهمه يعني دفع اموال لاحدى الممثلات
للصمت لشراء صمتها قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في نوفمبر من عام
طبعا الكثير من التعليقات من محامي ترامب
الذي
وصف يعني
التهم بانها اشبه بسيناريو في عالم مقلوب
راسا على عقب كما قال واضاف انها قضيه
اضطهاد سياسي ولكنه اكد ان يستعد للمواجهه
طبعا هناك لائحه اتهام غير معروفه حتى
الان كما اشارتي مع ناديه
ومايكل كوهن الشاهد الاساسي في الملف طلال
الحاج كبير مراسلي العربيه معنا الان اهلا
بك مجددا طلال اذا وصل بالفعل ترامب
بطائرته الى نيويورك ومن المفترض ان يستقل
سيارته بعد قليل للتوجه الى برج ترامب ما
ابرز ما يدور في ذهنك الان حول اللحظات
التاريخيه الحاسمه التي نشهدها الان وفي
الدقائق والساعات المقبله
طاهر اتفق معك بانها لحظات تاريخيه ولكن
لا اعرف ان كانت حاسمه ام لا فهذه تهم
الموجهه الى ترامب عاده عندما يوجهونها
الى الاعمال بانهم التصرف باموال شركه ما
هي جنح وليست جرائم ولكن في حاله ترامب
وفي حاله ايضا مايكل تم تصيدها الى درجه
جنايات او جرائم ويسمح بذلك قانون نيويورك
اذا كانت الجنحه
في التغط
يه جريمه وهذه الجريمه طبعا يتلاعب
بالانتخابات والتاثير على الراي العام
الوطني
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المهمه
هذه هي هو ما تمت ادانه مايكل عام 2018
وكانوا يريدون تقديم هذه الادله ايضا ضد
موكله
ولكن وزاره العدل تدخلت في ذلك الحين طبعا
لانه هو الرئيس الامريكي
واكتفوا فقط بتوجيه التهم هذه الى مايكل
قوي الذي حكم عليه بالادامه واصبح مجرما
وهو المحامي السابق لاكرم
وحكم بالسجن لمده ثلاثه عشر شهرا وبعد ذلك
وضعت تحت الاقامه الاجباريه في بيته لمده
ثلاث سنوات
كامله وهو الان مجرم يعني فلم كما يسمى
هنا في الولايات المتحده فتره
يجادل بان هذه تهم مزوره
ومسيفه
ولكن بها شخص اخر
يسير او ما ينطبق على المواطنين الاخرين
ينطبق على كل شخص في هذا البلد هذا ما
يجادل فيه الديمقراطيون
اصبح الشاهد الاول ضد ترامب في هذه لانه
هو من دفع الفلوس النقود او الشك الى
الثوم دانيال نيابه عن ترامب وكرام دفع له
المبلغ 130 الف دولار فيما بعد من خلال
شركته وهذا هو ما يسمى بالتلاعب والاحتيال
في عمل الشركات
الشركه وصفت هذه الاموال 130 الف دولار
دفعت مايكل كون لتعويضه
بانها مس
بتستحقات استفسارات القانونيه من مايكل
العمليه ليست
واضحه في واقع الامر هذه اول مره توجهتها
مثل هذه رئيس سابق والجميع لا يعرف الى
اين ستثير بنا المحاكمه لن تبدا غدا هذه
التهم ستقرا عليه غدا ولكن تحديد موعد
المحاكمه سيكون بعض الشهرين او ثلاثه
حينما تبدا المحاكم الفعليه تفضلوا طلال
ابقى معنا نتوجه الان الى مديره مكتب
العربيه ناديه البلبيسي من جديد ناديه
يعني فلنتحدث عن
الحواجز والاجراءات الامنيه المشدده حول
برج ترامب ومبنى محكمه من هاتن الجنائيه
بوسط المدينه يعني هل لمستم اي مؤشرات
وحتى دعوات
لاي عنف ربما قد يحصل هل هناك ما لفت نظرك
لا لا يوجد اي اولا لم ارى مؤيدين للرئيس
ترامب وانا اذكر يوم السادس من يناير
عندما كنا سنغطي فقط مظاهره عاديه لمؤيدين
رئيس انقلبت الى ربما اهم حدث هذا
الديموقراك الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
وبالتالي الشرطه الامريكيه كانت موجهه الي
اتهامات والحرس الوطني وغيره لم يكن هناك
حمايه كافيه بعد هذه الحادثه اعتقد بانه
خصوصا
معروفه بصراماتها وبخصوتها وبشدتها
وبالتالي نشر 30,000 عنصر من الشرطه
الامنيه سيمنع وقوع اي حادث عليه لان مع
انطلاق موكب ترامب ناديه من المطار من
الاغواردياف نيويورك ونشاهد هذا في جانب
من الصوره وفي الجانب الاخر نعيد بعضا من
لقطات وصول طائ مع مرافقيه الى ارض المطار
ونزوله من الطائره قبل ان يستقل احدى
سيارات موكبو متوجها الى برج ترامب في
نيويوركالي المتابعه
يعني امام المحكمه غدا لقراءه لائحه
الاتهام عليه كما هو مفترض قبل ان تبدا
المحاكمه في وقت لاحق قد يكون قد يكون
متاخرا قليلا كما قال طلال قبل قليل ناديه
اعذريني يجب ان اكتفي معك بهذا القدر للان
ولنعد اليك لاحقا نعم ويبقى معنا طلال
الحاج كبير مراسلي العربيه يعني نحن نشاهد
اذا هذه الصور من توجه موكب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الى برجه
الى برج ترامب في نيويورك قبيله يعني
قراءه او ليس توجيه الاتهامات ولكن قراءه
الاتهامات المعروف طلال بانه ترامب سيسلم
نفسه ما المعروف ايضا من الاجراءات
نعم سيسلم نفسه وسيدخل الساعه الحاديه عشر
بتوقيت المحلي السادس عشر بتوقيت جرينتش
يصعد الى طابق السادس السادس عشر الخامس
عشر معذره وهو الطابق الوحيد الذي يعمل
لان جميع قراءه المحكمه قفلت
سوف تقفل يوم غدا من الساعه 1:00 ظهرا
وسيمثل امام القاضي الساعه الثانيه والربع
بتوقيت المحلي او الثامنه عشر والربع
بتوقيت جرينتش العمليه المترو الامامي
الخاصي لن تستغرق
اكثر بالكثير وبعد ذلك
الى
الاكواديا والتوجه الى بطائره الخاصه الى
حيث سيقوم بقراءه بتقديم
المناصريه حول تجربته هنا في محكمته من
هاته الجنائيه العليا
وذلك في تمام الساعه 8:15 او الساعه
الرابعه والربع بتوقيت صباح
الخامس
بتوقيت دبي
نتوقع ان يكون في هذه
يعني هذه التوقعات طبعا انه
رجل بريء وان هذه
تهم ظالمه وانه
القضاء تم تسييسه كسلاح في
يعني
قضايا سياسيه وانه لو لم يرشح نفسه
للرئاسه ويكون هو الان بعد
مقاداته او اتهامه
المرشح الاول والاوفر حظا كان
رمزوق عليه في شهر وبدايه مارس باربع نقاط
هو الان متفوق علشان
31 نقطه في الاستطلاعات في معظم
الاستطلاعات وتمكن من جمع اربعه ملايين في
اليوم الثاني من توجيه التهمي اليه وجه
التهم اليه الخميس الجمعه تمكن من جمع
اربعه ملايين والان اصبح هذا المبلغ
7,000,000 دولار من المتعاطفين معهم من
الحزب الجمهوري وكل ذلك يصب في مصلحته
مهمه انك ذكرت موضوع الذي يسعى ايضا لنيل
الترشيح ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري هناك قاعده
بدون شك ترامبيه او جمه وريه تدعم ترامب
ولكن هناك اصوات بدات تظهر لو ركزنا عليها
معك قليلا تدعوه الى يعني الانسحاب من
السباق ومنهم الحاكم سابق لولايه اركانسا
ويقول بانه المنصب اهم من اي فرد الى اي
مدى على هذا الصوت في الايام الاخيره
ما زالت الاغلبيه تؤيد ترامب بين
الجمهوريين
حاكم ولايه
السابقه رشح نفسه للرئاسه ولذا لا يريد في
هذا السباق الرئاسي حيث ان المرشح الاول
والاخر حظا هو ترامب خاصه بعد توجيه التهم
اليه الان اقرب
منافس له هو رنده الذي يتراجع بنحو 31
نقطه وايضا
سفينه الولايات المتحده السابقه في الامور
المتحده
لا يوجد هناك من هناك
اذا استمر الوضع كذلك سيكون هو المرشح
الاول في حزب الجمهوري وهو يستخدم هذه
الانتخابات ممثل للحزب الجمهوري وسيفوز به
وعلى جانب الديمقراطي هل هناك هل هناك من
يلمس يعني محاولات تدخل من الاداره في هذا
الموضوع لانه الاداره على الاقل على صعيد
الرئيس واضح انه يحاول ان ينمى بنفسه كي
لا يتهم بتسييس القضاء
الجميع ينبى بنفسه الجميع ينبته خاصه في
الاداره الديمقراطيه لان هذه مساله
قانونيه فان تدخلوا اصبحت متيسه بالفعل
وهناك من يقول انهم يعرضون عليه اذا انكحب
بالانتخابات ان يتم الغاء كل هذه التهم
عليه ولكن هذا غير صحيح لان ذلك اثبات على
ان العمليات كانت مزيفه
الجميع اطلاق الامر والمده الى العام ليس
هو الرجل الذي اتهمه الذي اتهمته لجنه
محلفين عليا داخل هذه المحكمه الجنائيه
العليا في نيويو في منازل
ابراج السينما مصيبه فقط العام الماضي من
استلم هذا المنصب وبدا هذا التحقيق هو
ثابت بنك الذي بدا التحقيق في عام 2018
قبل اربع سنوات الان خمس سنوات
فارضا ما عمله هو استمرار في التحقيقات
وقدم ما لديه وما عمله الذي كان قبله الى
لجنه محلفين عليا وهم وهم من بعد دراسه
الادله والتحقيقات هم الذين قرروا ان
يوجهوا هذه التهم الى او الاغلبيه فيهم
ليس ليس بالاجماع قد تكون الاغلبيه كبيره
او صغيره لا اعرف ولكنها اغلبيه المح او
عشرين محلف في اللجنه العليا المحللين هم
قرروا توجيه هذه التهم رسميا الى الرئيس
السابق
اما القاضي
تفضل يعني
ما يدافع به ترامب عن نفسه يقول انا اتعرض
للاضطهاد السياسي
هذا صحيح هذا ما يقوله ويقوله
ويقول كبار شخصيات حتى الذين
ينافسون مثل
السابق في في بيت الابيض
والجميع والجميع
فيعني لا احد يريد ان يرى رئيسا امريكيا
توجه اليه التهمه كان رايك فيه هذه يمثل
الدوله يمثل
الولايات المتحده فتوجيهتهم اليه اهانه
للنظام الرئاسي الامريكي يعني في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده
بمناسبه الى وجهه وحتى اذا تمت
يمكن له ان يدخل السباق الرئاسي الادانه
بجرم لا يمنع
قليل الامريكيه
الدلفين
1920 عندما دخل مرشح هذه الانتخابات
وحصل على مليون شوت وهو في السجن فلذلك
رايت لن يمنع بالعكس بالعكس جمع مبالغ
كبيره من التبرعات لحملته الانتخابيه
وايضا حصل على
طفره كبيره في استطلاعات الراي تعاطفا معه
او نقمه على الدين لا اعرف ولكنه يطالب
بنقل هذه المحاكمه لانه في في معقل
الديمقراطيين هنا فيه ولا يعتقد انه سيحصل
على اللجنه المحلفين
عادله وهذا قد طلال نحن سنبقى مع الزملاء
وزميلات في متابعه هذا الموضوع طلال الحاج
كبير المراسلين شكرا جزيلا لك الان وشكرا
لناديه البلبيسي مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن في تغطيتها هذه من نيويورك هذه
المره ونعود اليكما تباعا في سياق هذه
التغطيه المتواصله مع صهيب شراير في اخبار
الساعه بعد لحظات صهيب اذا تبقي علينا
ايضا على هذا الموضوع اكيد طاهر وراويه
مساء الخير مره اخرى سنتابع موكب ترامبو
وصوله الى ترامب تاور هناك حيث سيمضي هذه
الليله بانتظار مثوله امام قادما هات غد
اليك تفضل شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]